the number of people attending the
yearly Abel town show is rising by 5%
per annum and the number attending the
le bouche Peep Show is falling by 5% per
annum in the first year under
consideration
5,000 people attended both shows which I
take to mean each of the shows
independently both had 5000 the same
number of people as opposed to 5,000 all
added together because if it was the
second and not the first you don't know
enough information to solve this
question now nonetheless I'm going to
show you how I do this because there is
actually a particular method that's
important for this question a particular
way of laying eggs out which will be
very very useful when we dive a bit
deeper next year into the applications
of series okay so let's set this thing
up right firstly vital details right
we've got this town and town it starts
at 5,000 they both start at 5,000 and
it's going up 5% every year so just
gonna write it plus 5% per annum okay
and you've got Bush Creek and this
struggling at the same amount okay mmm
bit suspicious anyway this is setup
you've got 5,000 people starting at each
one and then the first question they
asked is find the total number attending
each shown during the first six years
the total number attending each show
during the first six years okay this is
not too complicated to remember during
the first six years how they do this
when you do first six years there's a
couple of ways the question phrases have
been ambiguously but as you'll see
there's one of two ways to read it sorry
I should say there are two ways to read
it you're eventually going to need to
read the question both ways you need to
answer both questions okay so I'm going
to add to both and you'll see why it
doesn't matter which way you read okay
so what I'm looking for is and I'm just
going to call this you know a so
hey you need to introduce some language
so you can start to talk about likes
invitation or like I think so you can
start to deal with the numbers okay so
what I'm gonna do is let hey subscript
in I'm borrowing this language from when
we did a series we said sfm right but I
have two series that are gonna form here
okay so I'm gonna make this the a series
and I'm gonna have a B series as well so
and equals now here's my one of two
right here's my one up two and I'm gonna
justify why I choose one versus the
other
I can either read this as read the
question again find the total number
attending each show during the first six
years okay I can interpret this thing or
rather I can define it as alright how
many were in the first year and then how
many were in the second year and then
how many were in the third year I can do
it like that okay and then I just have
to work out I pointed out a 1 a 2 a 3 a
4 a 5 a 6 okay that can be my answer or
alternatively I can read it as find the
total nut but I don't want a 1 by itself
and a 2 by itself any three I want all
six years added together right so it's
like well this is how many I had in the
first year now let's add on how many I
had in the second year and the third
year for the fourth year and so on okay
now I'm going to go for option two which
is more work okay there's two reasons
why number one it's in an exercise about
series so I'm kind of suspicious I think
I'm gonna have to add this eventually
and when I look at the later parts right
for example when you look at Part C it
says what's the ratio of the total
number attending one show over these 25
years to the total attending the other
show so you're clearly gonna have to do
some summation here okay so I'm going to
defy this it's critically important to
to find it let a and B the total number
over the first n years of shows at
and years of shirt I hope that language
that way that I'm phrasing it makes
clear I don't just want how many in the
first order
18th or the 100th year I want all of
them cumulatively up to that year okay
over the first ten years at April 10th
right and then similarly CMN equals and
just for the sake of time I now normally
write out this whole thing but it's not
at okay are you right with that so let's
start for me to be serious right now
think back to what we first started
talking about sequences little bit
series right how many terms do I need to
uniquely define what a series is I need
three right so before I can get to an
expression for a sub M or B sub n I'm
gonna have to get a 1 a 2 a 3
likewise for B and off of those patterns
then I'm going to generalize okay does
that make sense and getting those three
steps is critical so let's start with a
1 a 1 this is the town that's growing
okay it's the town that's growing so the
first year they actually tell you it's
just 5,000 like that's by definition
that was just provided in the first year
under consideration 5,000 of people
people attended boat shows okay so they
want done when I do a tune okay what
happens here now I'm gonna write this in
a particular way right because this is
cumulative it's cumulative
right the first thing I've got to do is
I've got to include what happened in the
previous years
right so HM includes a word inner but
then in the second year I've got a new
audience right so I'm gonna add they're
born now this is the growing audience
right so it's going to have that 5,000
but what will I multiply it by in order
to get the size of the new audience okay
this is just the first year right so
it's like I had this amount plus 5% now
because I'm gonna be dealing in like you
know all of these whole numbers here I
don't really want percentages flying
around I'm gonna write as a decimal so I
will write it
like so okay that's really a contraction
of 1 plus 0.05 right
this is compound interest happening
right except it's audiences okay yeah
wouldn't it be surprised right because
your 1 is already included in your a 1
no that's a great question to ask the
answer's no the reason why is because I
want the entire audience not just how
much the audience is grown by ok to 0.05
if I want to go out to money talk that'd
be like my interest right but I actually
want the whole thing
I want the whole audience in the second
year okay are you right with that okay
now that's I'm almost done this is five
thousand plus five thousand 1.05 there
you go there's hm okay third year right
now I'm doing this cumulative lead right
so before I start working out anything
about the third year itself I need to
take into account the two previous years
right and that's a - you see what I'm
doing here you see how helpful it is to
think in the recursive definition right
I'm saying SN equals sorry SN equals SN
minus 1 plus TN do you see what I'm
doing here okay does anyone ask you
questions at this point okay okay so in
some senses the reason its cumulative is
because I've defined it too many
cumulative right I have to find it to be
the total number over those years okay
as opposed to how much in each year on
its own I suppose I could have defined
it that way if I wanted but it won't
help me solve these later questions
right so that's why I've defined it in
this way and also because like I'm
dealing with series this is what I'm
interested in great question now let me
just I've lost over that point really
quickly this line here I'll just write
underneath what it really is saying
SN equals SN minus 1 plus T and write
that recursive definition despite how
strange it is obviously useful it's how
this whole thing builds okay now that
I've got all the previous years right
how many you're gonna be in the third
year itself okay now be careful it's
growing by 5% each year so in the third
yeah right it's gonna take how many
people were there last year and increase
by 5% but we know that increasing by 5%
is a multiplicative growth right as
opposed to like 1.1 in fact it's not 1.1
it'll be one point I don't know what the
answer is okay you can work out on your
calculator okay but what point in five
times 0.05 is not going to be one point
of 1.5 plus point oh five what is that
one
yeah it's bigger it's bigger that's
right because it's compounding right
okay so now I've built that let me
actually evaluated here so this is a to
come here
there okay now you can see the series
now can't you it's starting to fall okay
so now that I've got my one two three
terms okay now I'm ready to generalize
and no sooner can you see at this point
I don't have nearly enough information
to generalize I mean not that it would
be but this could be an AP for all i
doing right from here to key what is
5,000 times 125 it'll be five thousand
eight seventy five five five two five
zero five two five zero of course fun so
there's a common difference of two
hundred and fifty there
the next type would be five and a half
thousand but it's not an utterly no by
the third time okay now I'm ready
generalize let's do it am okay now pay
careful attention through the numbers
and how the series grows right clearly
each series is starting off the same way
right so I'm going to include all of the
previous terms here right and to
establish the pattern of course I need
my first three terms right but if I go
all the way up into the eighth year
right dot dot dot what will my very last
term be okay I'm obviously gonna have
the 5000 the fun doesn't always appear
in x one I'm gonna have some number of
1.05 how many n minus n minus one do you
recognize this right do you recognize
the formulas this guy is a and minus one
got it okay now at this point all I'm
really interested in is actually think
back to the question I want a six you
see that first six years okay a ceases
just enough numbers that I could do this
manually like and it wouldn't take you a
ridiculous amount of time okay but as
you'll see pretty quickly they're gonna
ask me about like 10 years and 25 years
no thanks okay so instead I'm gonna take
the fact that this is GP I'll finish
this line and then we'll pick up period
but I'm gonna take the fact this is a GP
and get a sum out of it okay
carefully first this 75000 see I'm gonna
take them all out of the picture you
came back 5,000
once I factorize it I'll get this you
see that okay what have I done there now
don't miss this don't miss this right
we're gonna write this line and then I
get to get a sum and then on this miss
you this I'm gonna make a statement
about it okay now we'll discuss this
statement that I'm making in period 5
but for now I'm just going to hand it to
you okay
I want to identify this before I say
anything in terms of a formula so I'm
literally gonna stay away this is a GP
this is a GP wind now there are three
features that it's a partial Sun by the
way there are three features that define
a partial Sun right first turn common
ratio and what's the last one number of
terms thank you
eight are a ten okay so a equals 1 is
equal to 1.5 now please for the love of
same meeting for things don't say N
equals n okay don't do that because you
just looked like a tool alright instead
just write n times because with a equals
1 we are equals 0.5 with in touch thank
you if that's true then I can say
anything about this that applies to GPS
whoops namely my summation right so this
is say would be a times R to the n minus
1 all over aa minus 1 okay I'm gonna
stop there we'll pick up